Is Donald Trump lying about having been tested
for Corona virus and testing negative?
Now, I'm not suggesting Trump didn't test
negative, although it wouldn't surprise me
that if Trump had tested positive, they simply
wouldn't tell us.
But the timing, and especially Donald Trump's
very weird answer yesterday when he was asked
about what it was like to be tested.
It all sounds very strange.
And I don't know that Donald Trump was actually
tested.
So let's go through it.
First, starting with the question yesterday
during Trump's coronavirus press conference,
Trump's first answer about the timing and
results of his test rotavirus.
Friday night, the White House doctor's office
put out a statement around midnight Friday
saying that no test was indicated.
So when exactly was your test administered?
I had my test.
I was late Friday night.
And the reason I did it was because the I
had no symptoms whatsoever.
So the doctor said, you have no symptoms.
So we don't see any reason.
But when I did the press conference on Friday,
everybody was going crazy.
Did you do the test?
Did you do the tests?
So very late on Friday night, I did the tests.
And he may have put out or the doctor may
put out something that I don't know what time
the letter went out.
Maybe it was put up by somebody else.
But the results came back, I believe.
The following day and we tested negative.
Question How could the White House doctors
offices indicate implying that you haven't
had one when in fact you had?
Well, I told them that and I went totally
by what they said.
The doctors more than one.
They said you don't have any of the symptoms.
They checked what you're supposed to check.
And that I didn't have symptoms, but I did
it.
I did a test late on Friday night and it came
back probably 24 hours later or something.
They sent it to the labs, came back.
So understand the timeline that Trump is suggesting
here, combined with what we know Friday at
3:30.
Trump was asked during his press conference
about being tested and he said, I have no
symptoms.
I don't need to be tested.
But maybe someday I will be Friday evening.
The White House said Trump doesn't need to
be tested.
But then Trump now claims that late on Friday,
he was tested for Corona virus.
If the White House puts out a statement saying
nobody worry.
Trump doesn't even need testing.
Why would he have been tested basically at
the exact same time that the White House was
putting out that statement?
And then Trump claims that Saturday evening,
so fewer than 24 hours from when he was supposedly
tested, he got a negative test result for
a corona virus.
So the question is a good one.
If at 3:00 p.m., you said no symptoms, no
need for a test.
If at night a doctor said no symptoms, no
Why were you immediately tested?
And then there's also the question of tests
are taking longer than 20 hours or 18 hours.
Now, of course, maybe when it's the president,
they fast track it.
We don't know.
But they said that they are hopeful some day
we will get to 24 hour turnaround on tests.
We're not there yet at this point in time.
If the test was done very late Friday, as
Trump says.
And then early on Saturday evening, the results
were already announced.
That is way less than the 48 to 72 hour range.
That is typically the one that's also weird.
But then we get to the real whopper.
And this is this is what from me suggested
this guy's not been tested.
Trump was asked about the test.
And the test requires a swab to be inserted
pretty deeply into the nose to get to the
throat.
It's not comfortable.
Most people gag tier up, cough, et cetera,
which is why the people doing the tests have
to be in for medical protective gear.
And Trump responds in a way where it doesn't
seem like he knows how the test is done.
And so he says something very vague to avoid
saying something that is known to be untrue
about the test itself.
Check it out and let me know what you think.
That's not something I want to do every day.
I can tell you that it's you know, it's a
little bit of a it's a little bit of good
doctors in the White House.
But to test to test, it's a medical test.
Nothing pleasant about.
It's a test.
It's a medical test.
And I wouldn't recommend.
It's not something I would want to do again.
Does this sound to anybody else like a completely
fabricated story that he made up completely
on the spot?
So let me know what you think.
Do you think Trump is lying about having been
tested at all?
Do you think Trump is lying about the negative
result?
If you said to me, is the lie about the result
or is the lie about being tested?
I think the lies about being tested not not
not about the result, although I do think
they would likely lie about the result as
well.
Let me know what you think.
I don't know.